president Trump's approval ratings jump
migrants approach the southern border
and the left goes ballistic over the
Department of Education approach to sex
and gender I'm Ben Shapiro this is the
Ben Shapiro show well I hope that you
had an uneventful weekend we here at the
Daily wear had an eventful weekend which
means we had to go to politican and ruin
our Sunday that way but if you missed
politican this weekend we've got you
covered because subscribers get to watch
all daily wire events for free on the
website head on over to daily wire.com
slash subscribe to enjoy all the leftist
cheers produced over the weekend and
enjoy our weekend much more than I did
go check that out right now also before
we jump into today's news I would
recommend to you that if you are not
getting the sleep to which you feel
entitled perhaps you should get a better
mattress well the mattress that you need
is available over at helix sleep they
built a sleep quiz that takes two
minutes to complete they use the answers
to match your body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress
whether you're a side sleeper a hot
sleeper or they like a plush or a firm
bed with helix there's no more guessing
and no more confusion just go to helix
sleep calm slash men take their
two-minute sleep quiz that they will
match you to a mattress that will give
you the best sleep of your life four
couples helix can even split that
mattress down the middle providing
individual support needs and feel
preferences for each side the mattress
is really great my wife and I took the
two minutes sleep quizzes we ordered the
mattress it came in the mail we open the
box and inflate it right in front of us
popped it on the bed frame we were good
to go it's so good that we actually got
one for my sister for her wedding
they've a 10-year warranty and you get
to try it out for 100 nights risk-free
right now helix is offering up to 125
bucks off all mattress orders again up
to 125 bucks off at helix sleep calm /
Ben that's helix sleep calm / Ben again
125 bucks off your mattress order go
check it out right now helix sleep calm
/ pound use that / Ben so they know that
we sent you alright so the poles in the
lead-up to the midterm elections are
starting to look a lot better for the
Republicans the reason for this is
because Democrats suck at everything so
there's a lot of attempt on the right to
claim that this is all Republican
know-how and suddenly Republicans are
good at things no well it's really
happening here is that the Democratic
mask is often Democrats are garbage at
everything basically when President
Trump is the second thing in the news
that is a very good thing for
Republicans when he is the first thing
in the news it's a problem
so when Democrats spend weeks
demonstrating they don't care about due
process and that they will railroad a
guy simply for political reasons very
good for Republicans when the lead
headline is the leading 2020 contender
for the Democrats setting herself on
fire over a DNA sample that's really
good for Republicans when the lead
headline is Democrats approaching Ted
Cruz in a restaurant and screaming at
him and his wife very good for
Republicans the best friend of
Republicans right now is the insanity of
the Democrats and you are seeing that
full scale in the polls also obviously
you're seeing the effect of a very good
economy on the Republicans the margin by
which voters trust Republicans over
Democrats on the economy has never been
larger in the history of the polling
really say our +17 in this poll which is
amazing also I don't want to give no
credit to President Trump President
Trump has done a couple of very good
things number one he has taken proper
economic measures that have really
benefited the average American and
number two the President of the United
States does make it feel like he is a
change actor and usually in midterm
elections there's an attempt to vote for
change right now what the polls show is
that Republicans are actually seen as
the party of change well being the party
in power that's really unusual usually
the party out of power is seen as the
party of change but because Trump is so
out of left field and so outrageous and
so chaotic the benefit of that is that
he feels like a change agents even
though he is the guy who's sitting in
the seat that is very good for
Republicans so here is what the latest
polls show according to The Wall Street
Journal voter interest in the midterm
elections has surged from records within
both parties helping to drive up
president Trump's approval rating while
maintaining the Democrats lead as the
party most preferred to lead Congress
according to a new Wall Street Journal
NBC News poll the findings point to an
energized electorate buffeted by
dynamics that bring great uncertainty to
the outcome of an election just two
weeks away and what the polls kind of
show is that everything is narrowing
nearly 2/3 of registered voters show a
high level of interest in the election
that is the highest ever recorded in a
midterm election since the journal/nbc
poll began asking the question in 2006
now the reason for that is because
largely of the Democrats the Democrats
were always going to be energized to
vote against President Trump but now
Republicans are really mobilized to vote
against the Democrat I know that my
interest in voting peaked significantly
thanks to the Democrats
behavior during the Brett Kavanaugh saga
and I know that most other Republicans
feel the same the once large gap between
Republican voters and Democrats voters
interest in the election has now been
closed 68 percent of Republican voters
and 72 percent of Democrats say they are
very interested in the election that is
the highest recorded for either party by
the survey in a midterm election also
president Trump's Trump's job approval
rating has jumped to 47% according to
The Wall Street Journal and NBC News
poll that is the highest mark he has
ever had in office in that poll he is
now higher than President Obama's
average poll approval rating before the
2010 elections now it is worth noting
that President Obama got skunked in the
2010 elections but with that said
President Trump has gained significant
approval only 49 percent disapproving so
that's about as close to parody as Trump
is ever going to get he's never going to
be a 55% president he's just two
polarizing a figure 47% for president
Trump is a very good number and that is
a real action number if he gets up to
47% in the public approval ratings he
wins re-election in 2020 that's an
improvement from September that's when
44% approved and 52% disapproved of his
performance and then Democrats decided
it would be a great idea to shoot
themselves in the foot repeatedly with
an ar-15 and now president Trump has
soared in the approval ratings Democrats
still do lean on the question of which
party should control Congress among poll
respondents identified his likely voters
50 percent preferred Democrats forty-one
percent prefer Republicans which is
about the same as it was in last month's
poll but the blue wave is now running
into a riptide of uncertainty according
to certain holds certain pollsters
although Democrats are preferred in the
national poll overall here's the key
their advantage has vanished in the
House districts that matter most in
districts rated as the most competitive
by the nonpartisan cook Political Report
the parties are dead even on the
question of which one should control
Congress so that means that in
California Democrats are really fired up
in New York Democrats are really fired
up in Ohio now quite as much or at least
Republicans are just as fired up as
Democrats are in Ohio in last month's
poll this is an amazing thing in last
month's poll Democrats led by 13
percentage points among registered
voters and six points among likely
voters interest in the election has
jumped among many groups that tend to
favor Democrats Latinos African
Americans young people more than
two-thirds of black voters showed high
interest in the election that's up from
fifth
7% in the average of polls taken from
January through September but you were
also seeing a massive increase a massive
increase among white voters among
Republican voters among older voters
it's consistent so we do not know what
the case is here but there is a massive
gender gap and this massive gender gap
is again the result of two things
President Trump is toxic to women and
Democrats are toxic to men this is the
gender gap is not one factor it's not
that Republic it's not that men love
Republicans and love President Trump
because they hate women or anything like
that it's that President Trump is
uniquely off-putting to many women
particularly suburban moms and the
Democrats are supremely off-putting to
men and this is why you're seeing the
polls close the gender gap that has
actually opened up wide in the last
month is not between women and kind of
the normal electorate it's between men
in the normal electorate men are now
favoring Republicans in heavy numbers
this poll found Democrats with a
lopsided advantage among female voters
for the second month in a row women in
the survey say they prefer a Democrat
controlled Congress by 25 percentage
points 57 to 32 which is a massive gap
male voters however want Republicans to
lead Congress by a 14 point margin 52%
Republican 38% Democrats in competitive
swing districts are mostly in suburban
areas urban voters favor a
democratic-controlled Congress by a 36
percent margin rural voters favor the
GOP by 31 points among suburban
residents the parties are virtually tied
44% favored GOP control 45% favored a
Democratic Congress now why because
voters continue to trust the Republicans
on the economy on trade issues
Republicans are preferred by a 17 point
margin that's up from 8% in August the
issue has been in the spotlight because
President Trump was actually able to
close a NAFTA deal so all of the talk
about tariffs and trade wars that is
basically receded into the background so
all of this is good news for a public
does that mean Republicans hold the
house he's still more unlikely than not
but this upsurge is is pretty amazing
stuff for Republicans in the lead-up to
a midterm election and again a lot of
that has to do with the facts that the
Democrats are just terrible at
everything when I say they're terrible
at everything I mean they are completely
off-putting on the most basic basic
issues and that's what we are saying
that is the story of today's
Texas is hell off-putting the Democrats
are Mitch McConnell for example make
cocaine Mitch as we are fond of calling
him cocaine Mitch was eating at a
restaurant he was confronted by
protesters if this thing becomes
consistent it is not good for the
country and it is certainly not good for
the Democratic Party which seems to be
embracing it in a way the Republican
Party is not now Nancy Pelosi was also
confronted over the weekend and
protesters shouted to her the difference
is high-level Republicans condemned that
high-level Democrats are not doing a
great job of condemning what's going on
here look at these protesters confront
cocaine Mitch and Elaine Chad they're
eating at a restaurant and I mean
frankly they're just lucky that cocaine
Mitch didn't go ballistic on them and
tell them to say hello to his little
friend Manny I don't know why you'd want
to go up against cocaine mention Elaine
Chao it will claw out your eyes and feed
you to the Ravens but this is what these
protesters decided to do
here's what I love this how you know
it's Kentucky okay the way that you know
this is Kentucky is the protesters show
up and they start shouting at cocaine
Mitch and all the patrons let get the
hell out of here
nobody likes you leave yeah this is why
it's so funny I've been asked before if
anybody has ever confronted me at a
restaurant or tried to make trouble at a
restaurant and like no I eat kosher
those are all my friends right you come
into a kosher restaurant and you tried
to confront me these are all my buddies
and my security right the Jew crew okay
so we will we will fight you off but
cocaine Mitch basically has that in
Kentucky as well so he just activated
his his goons to basically fight back
against these guys just by sitting there
the cool collected turtle gotta love it
okay meanwhile Democrats determined to
show that they are just as nutty as you
think they are in other ways as well
they've decided that beta or Roarke is
the most important person on planet
earth he is deeply important why have
they decided beta Rock is important I
have no idea they're trying to say that
he's sort of like Barack Obama except
without half the charm or the racial
appeal but they're still trying to
manufacture this this kind of quasi
enthusiasm for beta or work and there is
a report from ABC News that really fond
over him last night but the best stuff
the best stuff from these campaigns then
it was true for President Trump and it's
the thing I despise most about politics
generally is true for Obama and from
anybody who has any level of political
notoriety has a certain number of fans
who are completely crazy and those fans
do completely crazy things in public I
don't mean wearing t-shirts or lining up
for book signing I mean what I'm gonna
show you in just a second because it's
astonishingly bad and really
embarrassing and you got to imagine that
these folks the day after the election
they wake up and they go what was I
thinking well it really was this what I
wanted to do with my life when I was
when I was 12 was this one the image
that I wanted to project to the world
will get to all that in just a second
first let's talk about blue apron okay
you need food delivered to your house in
prepackaged ingredients the freshest
best ingredients gourmet recipes it'll
come directly to you and then you can
cook with your family I love cooking
with my kids folks around the office are
using blue apron on a routine basis
because the food is great and also it's
just a great idea every time you go to
the grocery store and you go with a
shopping list first of all nothing more
annoying than that my wife and I have a
rule I asked her before I go to the
grocery store which ingredient she wants
me to forget because I will forget one
so she
welp rename the ingredients I'm going to
forget with blue apron you don't have to
worry about that everything is coming to
your door in the prepackaged portions so
you never getting too much or not going
to Costco and buying like 83 pounds of
tumeric instead you're getting exactly
what you need it's coming to your door
you're cooking these gourmet meals it's
dinner in as little as 20 minutes every
week at least three recipes are built in
for your busy schedule in mind boo apron
has done the meal prep for you they
prepared sauces and spices and
ingredients and they offer a range of
recipes bursting with flavors whether
you're looking for a quick and easy meal
or a Phil Q and Erin cooking experience
blue apron lets you choose from the
range of recipe options so check out
this week's menu get your first three
meals for free at blue aprons comm slash
Shapiro that's blue aprons kaam /
Shapiro's to get your first three meals
for free blue apron is indeed a better
way to cook and man i'm looking at some
of these recipes it's stuff like tomato
and basil pesto pizza that you're
cooking seared steaks and homemade steak
sauce with mashed potatoes I mean this
this is gourmet stuff you make in your
own home you don't have to go to a
restaurant be harassed by folks who are
gonna yell at you go instead to blue
apron , / Shapiro to get your first
three meals for free when I say folks
have have made fools of themselves for
bait or work I remember back in 2008
when the Democrats actually had small
children singing hymns to President
Obama then candidate Obama now Democrats
have gone even beyond that here is a
bunch of bait o O'Rourke supporters I
don't know why doing YMCA but be ETO in
unison it's not good
[Music]
[Applause]
now what I love about this most is the
move that was made by Democrats that
beta O'Rourke draws an incredibly
diverse crowd if you can't see this this
is all old white people and a small girl
that's really what it is it's like all a
bunch of all the white people who can
barely move it looks like workout night
at the local old-age home I mean it
looks like it does when you actually go
down to the YMCA and you see the people
who are 60 in the water doing physical
therapy except they're doing B eto for
Senate so that was strong but that was
not the strongest entry in the beta
worship him kn'l hey the strongest entry
comes courtesy of some crazy ladies who
decided to cut the weirdest video I've
seen in the selection cycle well I can't
say that I mean I've seen so many weird
videos in this election cycle I can't
but this one is pretty astonishing here
we go
I don't even know what this is but
listen if you can bear to Cruz yet
[Music]
[Applause]
this is not a parody of fado supporters
these are actual beta supporters I know
I know people telling me to cut this but
I can't mesmerizing it's mesmerizing way
bad this is not actually a parody of
beta supporters from what I understand
so good stuff they're from the beta
supporters really demonstrating that
they don't care too much about a guy
driving over a median line being super
drunk and crashing into a trunk and then
fleeing and also I mean I can see why
they don't care that much about
drunkenness considering you would have
to be drunk to think that was a good
idea but there you are so I can't
imagine why Republicans are responding
the way that they are except for
Democrats again the theme of today's
show Democrats terrible at everything
continuing with that theme my the woman
who I've chosen to cat call on a routine
basis Alexandra Ocasio Cortese the
future congresswoman from Brooklyn over
the weekend again
you wonder why folks in the United
States are not taking Democrats maybe as
seriously as they should because they
don't deserve to be taken seriously here
is Alexandra Ocasio cortez over the
weekend saying that we should fight
global warming the same way we fought
the Nazis well I don't see really how
bombing the Germans is gonna help but I
mean I'm willing to try if she is it
here is Alexandra Ocasio Cortez
suggesting that I guess we're supposed
to
I don't know invade Normandy to stop
global warming or something here she is
the most intelligent advocate for her
position the left can present these days
Alexandra Ocasio Cortez it's very
difficult to hear her what she says the
LAT when we talk about existential
threats we can stop her because it's
very difficult to hear because when we
talk about existential threats the last
time we had a really major existential
threat to the country was around World
War two so she knows nothing about
history there was an entire Cold War
that existed for several decades after
World War two as it turns out she said
until we've been here before and we have
a blueprint of doing this before right
when we bombed the Germans
I mean don't don't stop her she's
rolling she's none of these things are
new ideas what we had was an existential
threat in the context of a war we had a
direct existential threat with another
nation this time it was Nazi Germany an
axis who explicitly made the United
States as an enemy as an enemy history
lessons with Alexandra Ocasio Hurd has
her some of my favorite history lessons
we had a direct existential threat with
another nation this time it was Nazi
Germany and access not Axe body spray
okay
you mean the Axis powers oh that's what
you mean so and what we did was we chose
to mobilize our entire economy and
industrialized our entire economy and we
put hundreds of thousands if not
millions of people to work in defending
our shores and defending this country we
have to do the same thing in order to
get us to 100% renewable energy and
that's just the truth of it so we need
to draft every male of military age have
them live in barracks for four years
ship them overseas put women in the
factories and ration the butter good
idea good yeah don't see how that's
going to go around why don't we take
them seriously I just don't understand
speaking of not taking them seriously a
very serious issue right now is cropping
up on America's southern border so as
folks know I'm pretty libertarian when
it comes to immigration I'm somebody who
believes that there should be free
movement of labor not citizenship you
shouldn't be able to come in the United
States become a citizen and vote you
shouldn't be able to
taxpayer dollars but if you want to come
here and work I really don't have a huge
problem with it but even I a libertarian
on immigration believe that we ought to
have actual borders in the United States
meaning defensible borders you don't
just get to cross our borders because
you'll want to cross our borders a
country without borders is not actually
a country this Caravan issue is a
serious issue this is according to The
Associated Press this morning a growing
caravan of Honduran migrants streamed
through southern Mexico on Sunday
heading toward the United States after
making an end run around Mexican agents
who briefly blocked them at the
Guatemalan border they received help at
every turn from sympathetic Mexicans who
offered food water and clothing hundreds
of locals driving pickups vans and cargo
trucks stopped them to let them clamber
aboard
Bessy shackling lopez of the Honduran
city of San Pedro Sula carried a stuffed
polar bear in a winter cap that seemed
out of place in the tropical heat it's
the favorite and only toy for two
daughters four year old Victoria and
three year old Elizabeth who trudged
beside her gleaming with sweat listen
I've sympathy for folks who want to
escape crappy places to come for a
better life that doesn't mean the United
States has an obligation to take in
anyone who wants to get in without any
sort of vetting procedures or
determination as to whether this person
is going to help the country or not
that's not the way this works we live in
a different time than we did in 1907
when there was no vast welfare state for
people to take advantage of when the
structure of the economy was
substantially different again I'm for
free movement of labor but you have to
control your borders she says my goal is
to find work for a better future for my
daughters I have sympathy for that go
claim asylum or tried to apply through
legal immigration means you don't just
get to march across the United States's
southern border and yet the left has
claimed that's exactly what should
happen President Trump has taken to
Twitter to respond to all of this we
will get to that and here's what he said
he says hey you know we'll get to that
in just one second president Trump's
response to the migrant crisis and the
Democratic response to the migrant
crisis but first let's talk about your
home security so ring calm does an
amazing job of ensuring your home
security they've actually sent us some
footage of ring busting crooks in the
act this one is pretty frightening we'll
just have to watch it hello
hey hey leave my house I'm calling the
police
okay what you need to do hey Sam's my
house stops now or I'm calling the
police why would you tell me that
because you're trying to push my door in
leave now
smash what's in there I'm calling the
police
okay I am the police needless to say he
was not in fact the police a lot happens
at your front door
get a ring video doorbell you'll never
miss a visitor and more importantly you
can make sure who it is yet your front
door before you open up with your home
or way you can see speak to visitors on
your smartphone from anywhere even share
video clips to neighbors using the ring
app go check it out right now and you
can get rings flood light cam their spot
like heaven let you build a ring of
security around your entire property
save up to 150 bucks on a ring of
security kit at ring comm slash Ben that
is ring calm slash Ben again 150 dollars
off when you go to ring calm slash Ben
so president Trump has responded to this
growing caravan of migrants that have
left Latin America and are moving up
through Mexico Latin in Central America
and moving up through Mexico and toward
the United States border he has
responded I think properly by pointing
out a couple of things one we need
border security to the countries that
are allowing them to do this are doing
so with the intent of creating a
pressure situation on our southern
border why should we continue funding
governments that are going to continue
creating those situations if the Huns
are in government is going to allow
folks to simply walk over the border to
Mexico with the intent of going to the
United States why exactly would we be
funding that government same thing is
true of the Mexican government same
thing is true of the Salvadorean
government there is no reason for us to
back government's that are going to
create pressures on our southern border
without actively working with us on the
immigration issue President Trump says
full efforts are being made to stop the
onslaught of illegal aliens from
crossing our southern border people have
to apply for asylum in Mexico first and
if they fail to do that the US will turn
them away the courts are asking the u.s.
to do things that are not doable that's
correct that's correct we do have
procedures one of the problems here is
that you can actually show up at a point
of entry and you can apply for asylum
that's the legal way to do this that's
not what these
hands are doing some of these caravans
are simply finding places that are open
in the United States border and crossing
there Trump says the caravans are a
disgrace to the Democrat Party changed
the immigration laws now now I'm not
sure what immigration laws who wants
changed specifically we actually just
have to enforce the laws that are
already on the books are not allowed to
legally enter the country we are allowed
to deport people we can streamline that
process maybe those are the laws who
wants change but it is true that the
Democratic Party has been using the
immigration issue as a club against
Republicans suggesting that Republicans
don't care about Latino folks because
they want to defend America's borders
that argument isn't working very well
specifically because a lot of Latinos in
the United States are also interested in
living in a country with borders they're
not interested in living in a country
where anyone can go and come as they see
fit one of the great lies of the media
is that everyone agrees with an open
borders agenda virtually no one in the
United States actually agrees with an
open borders agenda and it's pretty
obvious that there is an actual agenda
to this Caravan it's organized not only
is it organized it's organized for the
cameras the AP reports hundreds of
migrants applied for refugee status in
Mexico in the southern city of Judah
Hidalgo by Sunday evening the Interior
Department reported it had received more
than a thousand requests but most of
them were not doing this a far bigger
group forded the sushi at river from
Guatemala to the Mexican side
individually and dozens at a time and
resume the trek at first light marching
ten abreast on the highway csepp who
though they chanted in Spanish yes we
did well we don't have to let those
people cross the border the throne grew
even larger when the migrants arrived at
the border bridge swelling overnight to
five thousand it was not immediately
clear where the additional travelers
came from since about 2000 had been
gathered on the Mexican side Saturday
night presumably some of those folks are
from Mexico they're not necessarily from
countries to the south of Mexico their
destination on Sunday was the city of
tapa Tula in the Chiappa state under a
Blazing Sun small groups of twenty to
thirty paused to rest in the shade of
trees on the side of the road by
afternoon the caravan had evolved into
long lines of walkers straggling for
miles basically what this looks very
much like is the middle eastern
migration that has swamped a lot of
Europe that's what this looks like just
visually now the numbers are not the
same obviously as you're seeing from
immigration and from North Africa and
the Middle East into islands off the
coast of Italy but
the image the imagery is the same it's
it's a group of folks who are trying to
escape a worse life and simply cross the
border illegally into the United States
again the United States is a sovereign
nation we can't afford to simply take in
everybody that we would want to take in
out of economic necessity or out of out
of some sort of sympathy for the folks
crossing the border you cannot have a
country that is the strongest economy on
planet earth taking in thousands and
thousands of people illegally without
vetting them and without any sort of
skillset that does not make for a good
economy this is one of the reasons why
it's so funny folks on the Left they
love Norway they love Denmark they love
Sweden the immigration restriction
isnora way Denmark and Sweden you cannot
actually have a full-on socialist state
in terms of redistribution of wealth
when you have an underclass that is
coming that does not have a skill set
one of one of the things about about
those northern Nordic countries the
Scandinavian countries is that they
basically bans immigration well the
United States the left in the United
States wants it both ways they want
full-on open immigration at the same
time that they want to raise social
spending to Heights never before seen in
human history that is not a recipe for
victory and that's why President Trump
the Republicans are gonna win on this
issue even Lindsey Graham was a real dub
on immigration right Lindsey Graham
famously
one of the gang of eight along with John
McCain a big fan of immigration for him
even he said listen this is not
something we can do Nancy Pelosi would
welcome these caravans I don't know it
happened Lindsey Graham whether he
bumped his head or something but Lindsey
Graham 2.0 the reset is really good and
here is Lindsey Graham senator from
South Carolina saying Nancy Pelosi will
welcome these caravans do you want to be
the country of people that run you up
and down the hall and spit on you or do
you want to be a country of Republicans
who can actually deliver for working
families out there that will put good
judges on the court that will stand up
to the enemies of this country Nancy
Pelosi will welcome the caravans here
Donald Trump and the rest of us will
stop them
okay well that that is exactly right and
that's not out of lack of sympathy oh
that's because a country that has a rule
of law must abide by that rule of law
Democrats who continue to push this
issue are going to lose it's funny
because Democrats are so ensconced in
their own bubbles I mean what polls
shows that Democrats have far fewer
Republican friends than Republicans have
Democrat friends
because Democrats who live in blue areas
actually see Republicans as nasty evil
human beings and so they won't even talk
to them
they actually believe that it's a
mainstream view that people should be
able to flood into the country they
actually believe that it's a mainstream
view that gender and sex are completely
separate and not only that that if a man
calls himself a woman that that man is
then a woman the latest evidence of this
I mean there's an amazing story is the
way the media are covering an attempt by
the Department of Education to define
what title nine actually says so here's
the headline from the New York Times
today
it says transgender could be defined out
of existence under trump administration
now when you read that headline what
does that sound like to you
it sounds like the Trump administration
is saying there are no such thing as
transgender people or people who suffer
from gender dysphoria or gender identity
disorder that's what it would sound like
from that headline is that what's
actually happening no that's not what's
actually happening because that's
idiotic and nobody is saying there
aren't people who are transgender what
the Trump administration is saying is
that under the law laws that have to do
with sex discrimination are specifically
focused on biological sex they're not
focused on you thinking you are a member
of a different sex so when the Civil
Rights Act was written and it included
language about men and women and sex
discrimination it did not mean that it
is sex discrimination for you to say
that a man who shows up in a class from
a fifth grade class from dressed as a
woman and you say that's not cool we're
not going to do that that's not the same
thing as saying a woman can't work in
the classroom that's not sex
discrimination okay that's that's what
the Trump administration is saying
they're saying that behavior by men is
not the same as being female that's the
actual I'll read you the actual article
it doesn't it doesn't ban transgender
people that's not what what they are
doing the media is so dishonest with
regard to how they cover transgender
issues because they refuse to even
acknowledge the fact that there is such
a thing as biological sex it's utterly
self-defeating whether what the left
suggests is that gender and sex are
exactly separate but gender is sex
all right so gender and sex are
completely separate you can be a man but
your gender is female and that makes you
a biological female that makes you an
actual woman this is how they want to
read the law that makes no sense under
any circumstances I will explain in just
one second they think this is winning
issue
I mean it's just it's insane it's insane
first let's talk about that thing that
clunky awful thing you're wearing around
your wrist you want something nice you
want something that looks like this I
mean let's be real checked out that
watch it's a nice watch try me that's a
nice clean looking watch it's classy
well designed well what you need is a
movement watch movement has come pretty
far from being crowdfunded kids working
out of a living room in the past year
they've not only introduced a ton of new
watch collections for both men and women
they've also expanded to sunglasses and
fashion-forward bracelets I have 2
movement watches my wife has a movement
watch my mom has a movement watch so
does my father there what's great about
them is they're really kind of
minimalist and classy looking and they
are not expensive ok they are they are
luxury looking watches at non luxury
prices movement watches are not going to
tell you how many steps you've taken how
many calories you've saved they're just
going to tell you the time that's it
that's what they do and they are very
good at that movement watches start at
just 95 bucks at a department store
these would cost you three four or five
hundred bucks movement figured out by
selling online they can cut out the
middleman and retail markup providing
the best possible price they have
classic design quality construction
styled minimalism and you get 15% off
today with free shipping and free
returns by going to MVM t.com slash
Schapiro see why the movement keeps
growing MVM t-dot-com slash appear for
that discount 15% off MVM t.com slash
Schapiro go join the movement okay so we
are going to get to more of the the left
Bazaar take on science in one second but
first you're gonna have to go and
subscribe for daily wire calm yet $9.99
a month is the subscription that's it
you get the rest of my show live you get
the rest of Andrew Clavin show live
there are some michael moles a show live
you get access to things like our
performance at politican yesterday which
ruined my weekend but may make your week
i don't know maybe you'll enjoy it more
than I enjoy being there but I'm
thinking I enjoy being there with all
the folks who are in the book line but
it was a Sunday guys it was a Sunday in
any case go check it out right now at
daily Wired icon $9.99 a month or $99 a
year got the annual subscription it
comes along with this he left his tears
hot or called tumblr you'll enjoy it
you will live it you will love it you
will feel the power emanate into your
very being your soul may nearly leave
your body when you feel the joy that we
will experience upon grasping left is
tears hot or cold tumblr but don't worry
you won't die you'll just be lifted up a
level in terms of your spirituality you
can do all that for just 99 dollars a
year so what are you waiting for go
check it out also so
scribe to our feed over at YouTube or
iTunes leave us a five-star review
we only accept 5-star reviews if you try
to do anything else we'll just reject it
so don't even bother five-star reviews
over at iTunes it helps us with the
rankings over there plus that means that
you get our Sunday special this week
Sunday special is Andrew Klavan next
week Sunday special is pretty awesome
I can fairly state it will be great so I
can't reveal who the guest is suffice it
to say spectacular go check it out right
now we are the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast in the nation
[Music]
soin president Trump rails at the fake
news this is what he's talking about
this sort of headline from the New York
Times
transgender could be defined out of
existence under Trump administration
we're just gonna disappear the
transgenders now no that is not what
they're doing okay here's what they're
doing quote the Trump administration is
considering narrowly defining gender as
biological immutable condition
determined by genitalia at Birth the
most drastic move yet in a
government-wide effort to roll back
recognition and protections of
transgender people under federal civil
rights law
well because gender is biological and
immutable and it is delivered at birth
now what the left has said is they've
redefined the terms one of the great
areas of confusion in the transgender
debate is what the hell everyone's
talking about really I mean that because
sometimes when people on the Left say
gender what they mean is expressed
feminine or masculine qualities and
sometimes what they mean is actual sex
and it is impossible to tell which
unless they actually specify and then
they shift the definition based on what
they want their point to be so if you
say okay I accept that there's such a
thing as an effeminate man because there
are men who are effeminate okay and they
say no that means they're a female you
say no no that doesn't mean that they
are biological female they said well it
means they are a female gender say well
no it means that they are an effeminate
man a man with feminine qualities and
they say well but there there are
thousands of genders here's the problem
with defining gender as the expression
of effeminacy or masculinity this means
that there are literally 6.8 billion
genders 7.3 billion genders however many
people there are on the planet that's
how many genders there are because we
each have an individual amount of
effeminate or masculine characters
characteristics right we all have
individual amounts of masculinity of
testosterone and estrogen we are all
created differently okay based on
genetics and environment so if you're
going to say that there are only that
the left is really the one making the
case they're only two genders they're
saying that if you're an effeminate man
you're actually a woman and if you're a
masculine woman you're actually a man if
you want to define gender as just
expressed characteristics of femininity
or masculinity there are 7.3 billion
genders on planet earth which means it's
meaningless it's a word that means
nothing if you want to say that gender
has to do with biology now you have to
separate it into sex sex is based on Y
chromosomes and X chromosomes now there
are intersex people
is a very very small percentage of the
population that is not the argument
being made by transgender advocates
they're arguing that you can be fully
genetically male and still female all of
this makes no logical sense it's
completely confusing because it makes no
sense there is no internal consistency
or logic to the transgender civil rights
movement they can't even define their
terms if they simply want to say people
should be treated well I'm with you if
they want to say that I have to pretend
that a man who says he has a woman is a
woman the Caitlyn Jenner is just as much
a woman as my wife give me a freakin
break and everyone with half a brain on
planet Earth knows this hey but here is
what the New York Times says a series of
decisions by the Obama administration
loosened the legal concept of gender in
federal programs including an education
and health care
recognizing gender largely as an
individual's choice and not determined
by the sex assigned at birth first of
all sex assigned at birth is the dumbest
term in the world he was a gender
assigned at birth at least now you're
being consistent with the terminology
but even in that sentence you can see
the terminology shifting right there's
gender and then there's sex assigned at
birth you don't assign a sex at birth
babies are born they are what they are
when my girl was born she was a girl I
didn't assign her girl you know who
assigned her girl genetics god that was
sort of baked in you know how I know
because she's a girl
my god people and the same thing with my
son when he was born you know how I knew
he was a boy I looked at him wow this
was difficult and it turns out he is in
fact a boy amazing that the coincidence
he comes out and he has all male
characteristics and that he's also a boy
unreal
just amazing almost scientific ooh okay
so here's what they say the policy
prompted fights over bathrooms dormitory
single sex programs and other arenas
where gender was once seen as a simple
concept conservatives especially
evangelical Christians were incensed I
love the New York Times conservatives
especially evangelical Christians were
incensed this is their way of slandering
religious people as bigots it's not
people who actually use their brain and
recognize that there are men and women
and these are two separate categories
and that maybe there are women's groups
that want to remain women's groups and
not have men who believe they're women
in those groups and the same thing for
men's groups and the same thing for
bathrooms no it must be that they're
it's those crazy people who believe in
the Jesus it's those people the people
if it weren't
those crazies who believe in the Jesus
then it would then everything would be
fine then we could all acknowledge the
men and women are exactly the same
except for a little bit of appendage
down below here's what the New York
Times says now so here's the bad stuff
okay what's the bad thing the Trump
administration did now the Department of
Health and Human Services is
spearheading an effort to establish a
legal definition of sex under title 9
the federal civil rights law that bans
gender discrimination and education
programs that will receive government
financial assistance according to a memo
obtained by the New York Times the
Department argues in its memo that key
government agencies needed to adopt an
explicit and uniform definition of
gender as determined on a biological
basis that is clear grounded in science
objective and administrative all the
agencies proposed definition with
defined sex as either male or female
unchangeable and determined by the
genitals a person is born with according
to a draft review by the times any
dispute about one sex would have to be
clarified using genetic testing how in
the world is that not just basic
rationality if you claim you're a woman
I should be able to objectively tell
whether you're a woman or not it
shouldn't be up to it shouldn't be up to
you to decide and it's amazing to me
that the same left that has now come
around to Elizabeth Warren is not of
Native American because not well if she
says she's a Native American why isn't
she Native American she should be why
not she is more Native American than
Caitlyn Jenner as a woman so what
exactly is the problem here it's truly
amazing so okay you wonder why the right
doesn't trust the media you wonder why
people are resonating to the right it's
because the left insists that we
absolutely frontally lobotomize
ourselves on basic concepts like what is
a woman and what is a man and we're
supposed to pretend it's a great evil
when the Trump administration says
gender discrimination means
discriminating against women not
discriminating against men who believe
they are women it's an amazing thing
don't explain more in just one second so
title 9 of the Civil Rights Act was
specifically written with discrimination
against women in mind this is what title
mine of the Civil Rights Act does right
title mine bars discrimination under the
Civil Rights Act that is what it is for
hey it says this is what title 9 says
okay quote is from the Education
Department no person in the United
States shall on the basis of sex be
excluded from participation in be denied
the benefits of or be subjected to
discrimination under any education
program or activity receiving federal
financial assistance now notice the word
that is used there no person in the
United States shall on the basis of sex
of sex not of gender now even if it had
said on the basis of gender in 1972 that
still would not have meant gender as the
transgender left wants to explain gender
now in 1972
nobody was foolish enough to believe
that a man who said he was a woman was
actually a woman nobody okay this is not
a thing and so to redefine so there
they're doing a twice switch here okay
they're doing a linguistic and legal
twice switch here what they are saying
is number one that provision of title
nine doesn't refer to sex it refers to
gender and gender is just expressed
feminine or masculine characteristics
then they are saying that by gender we
actually mean sex so a woman who says
she is a man is actually a man so just
to get this straight title nine which
was designed to protect women from male
discrimination now is designed to
protect men who believe they are women
from discrimination on the basis of
discrimination against women no no I'm
sorry this is like just no there's
nothing in the law that suggests any of
this and for the left to go nuts over
this or suggest transgender people are
being to find out of existence no but
this is saying is there needs to be an
objective measure of male or female
before we can determine whether someone
is being discriminated against on the
basis of their sex as opposed to the
basis of their behavior now you can
still outlaw discrimination on the basis
of behavior if you really think this is
an important thing why don't you just
try to pass a law this is see this is
where it why the left won't actually do
what they want to do if the left
actually did what they say they want to
do what they would do is they would pass
an anti-discrimination law that would
say no school can fire any man who shows
up dressed as a woman at work right this
is it this is what they would say no
school can take any action against
anyone based on perceived gender
identity they can actually do this but
instead because the left wants to hijack
the law is what the Obama administration
did they are forcibly rewriting
regulations in order to carve the heart
out of laws and interpret them in
exactly the reverse of what they were
meant to be if the left can't win
elections they'll do it through a
regulation they did the same
with regard to carbon emissions they
tried to use the Clean Air Act in order
to regulate carbon emissions there is
nothing in the Clean Air Act that
suggests carbon emissions can be
regulated by the EPA win an election
guys you want to do this stuff win an
election and then pass legislation that
you think the American people like and
then we can answer as to whether we
think you're right or wrong but they
don't want to actually do that instead
they just want to sit outside and shout
and scream like small children okay
meanwhile this is a story that I just
have to touch on because I think that it
is important and obvious we have
forgotten all the obvious things in our
society obviously I mean that's
basically what this today's show has
been about global warming is not Nazism
and we can't respond in the same way
also America has borders and we have to
enforce them
also men are men women are women men who
believe they are women are not in fact
women and trying to define gender and
sex as the same thing sometimes and to
find them as completely separate other
times leads to linguistic and
terminological confusion these are
obvious things other obvious things
you're going to be happier in your life
if you have less sex partners before you
get married in the Atlantic now has
reported on a study over at the
Institute for Family Studies
Nicholas Wolff anger is a sociologist at
the University of Utah he's found that
Americans who have only ever slept with
their spouses are the most likely to
report being in a very happy marriage
meanwhile the lowest odds of marital
happiness about 13 percentage points
lower than a one woman partner belonged
to women who have had six to ten sexual
partners in their lives for men there's
also a dip in marital satisfaction after
one partner but it's never low as it
gets for women this is what the graph
shows why because marriage is a very
good institution and it turns out that
when you reserve yourself for marriage
and you make sex special and connected
to a level of emotional and spiritual
intimacy you are likelier to lead a
happier life I speak as someone who has
led this life my wife also led this life
thank God my parents led this life I
think that is a good life and the
promise of the sexual revolution that
free sex all around is going to make
everyone happier is a bunch of crap it
is not true it has never been true it is
a false promise act morally you will
live a happier life
attach yourself to one human being and
recognize that sex is more than just
getting your rocks off you will leave
you will lead a happier life and by the
way your sex life will be happier too
all of this should have been obvious but
we as a civilization have decided to
discard
in favor of the attractive and that of
course is a huge mistake
okay time for a couple of things I like
and then some things I hate will do a
Federalist paper so things that I like
over the weekend
Andrew Klavan who is not quite as
execrable as Michael moles he he he gave
me some reading recommendations one of
the things I love about having drew in
the office is that we are constantly
talking books and literature and going
back and forth recommending books to
each other my there's a great meme that
I saw today you know have you seen that
that meme from what what's the show
where the guys are throwing the chair at
each other
what's it we have a room full of humans
you know that you know the the meme of
the guy shouting at each other and then
one picks up a chair and throws the
chair at the other guy okay
is it bounty hunters I'm trying remember
in any case it's the there's a failure
it's a very famous meme online in which
these two guys are arguing one picks up
a chair and throws the chair at the
other guy and people have sort of pasted
in text so the meme shows a guy one of
the guys saying to the other guy it was
saying to the other guy you already have
enough books and the other guy saying no
I want to go to the bookstore and the
guy says the first guy says read the
books you already have and the second
guy's like but I want new books and then
he throws a chair that's me to myself
every day and so drew is constantly
recommending new books my book my book
pile around my bed is now I believe 45
deep and it just continues to grow but I
knocked out a couple over the week it's
American Chopper that's what it is okay
so in any case one of the books that
drew recommend it and it was a quick and
easy read is the book submission by
Michelle Wie Lebec which I'm obviously
mispronouncing this book was a massive
bestseller in France was translated into
English what's hilarious about this book
is because Weill Beck is a very famous
author the left in the United States has
to take him seriously even though he's
obviously supremely right-wing it is a
very very right-wing book it's not
right-wing for the reason that a lot of
people think it is the basic plotline is
that the Muslim population in France has
grown to such an extent that the Muslim
Brotherhood has a party in France that
wins 21 percent of the votes they get
into a runoff with the National Front
led by marine lepen and they form a
coalition with the Socialists in order
to actually win the presidency of France
in the process they decide to privatize
a lot of the education system and create
an Islamic education system the main
character is a professor in that
education system
who basically has to decide whether to
convert to Islam to maintain his job or
not
now a lot of people have taken this as
Legolas and Islamophobic novel and
showing about the evils of Islam now it
does talk at length about the evils of
radical Islam I talked about the fact
that Islam is patriarchal and and okays
polygamy and is okay with the
mistreatment of young women and all of
the rest of it but what the book is
really about more than any of that is
the emptiness of the West how the West
has completely completely ripped away
the heart of its own content that the
original appeal of West was based on
eternal truths and religious values and
those values have been completely
subsumed under the rubric of an empty
humanism that gives people no reason to
actually live with meaning basically we
have said to ourselves that we can
substitute hedonism sex a nice happy
feeling about others for actual drive
toward doing something worthwhile with
your life and so the main character in
the novel basically goes around in this
kind of empty post Christian Europe
feeling like he's got nothing to keep
him going and having promiscuous sex
with as many people as he basically
wants and eventually he realizes that
he's got nothing going for him I don't
want to give away the ending of the book
suffice it to say but the book is really
more a critique of Western Europe than
it is abyss LOM it's much more of a
critique of what the Europeans have done
to take away their reason for existing
and that this is leading to the complete
hollowing out of one of the great
civilizations in world history it's well
worth reading now it is x-rated Welo
becca is sort of famous for his sex
scenes I will say they are incredibly
raunchy you can skim them so that's the
good news it's only about a 240 page
book I'll cut out about 70 pages of the
book if you just skip the sex scenes so
it becomes a lot shorter read but it is
it's worth it's worth reading because
his take on what Western civilization
has become is I think what is is worth
while the non-fiction version of this
book not about Islam but about the
emptiness of what's happened in the West
is my book which is coming out next year
we have the cover for it it looks it
looks really good I can't wait to bring
it out is really exciting alright time
for some things that I hate
all right so late last week a couple of
actresses decided that fairytales were
bad Kristen Bell was probably maybe half
joking but there is this talk by Kristen
Bell and Keira Knightley that princesses
don't need to be saved we don't need to
read stories to our daughters about
princesses being saved here's the
reality princesses do need to be saved
and princes need to be saved men need
women women need men we save each other
this is what fairy tales are largely
about right even if you read the fairy
tale of Rapunzel at the at the very end
of Rapunzel the guy carves his way
through a thicket no actually it's
Sleeping Beauty the actual isn't which
one does he go blind there in the
original fairy tale there's one where
guy has to carve his way through a
thicket of thorns I believe it's
Sleeping Beauty and and he end and he's
actually blinded in the process and only
when the princess cries it into his eyes
is is he really can I can't member
that's Rapunzel or Sleeping Beauty in
the original version I'm sure our
emailers will tell us hundreds of them
in any case the idea that fairy tales
are all about female submissiveness and
men sexually abusing women is just
ridiculous so that didn't stop of course
Amnesty International from suggesting
that Sleeping Beauty and Snow White are
completely evil because women have have
it's Rapunzel that's why I thought that
women have fallen into these spells and
now they must be awakened with the kiss
of true love
there's no consent though guys there's
no consent so Amnesty International cut
this absurd little video that has
nothing to do with the actual fairy tale
and then they suggested that this was
what the fairy tale is okay for those
who can't see it's a prince approaching
sleeping princess in the blend
and he goes in for the kiss but then he
decides that he's instead going to
sexually abuse the woman by putting his
hand between her legs because this is
what happened in the fairy tale
obviously seriously dude seriously what
this not nice cool I'm a prince she's a
princess we were gonna you know we
messed around at the party so we're just
picking up where we left off but did she
you into it now
she told me earlier she wants to be from
the P from the P yeah that's me the
prince the P I'm the P here Prince what
you should have made a contract or
something no but I mean did you ask her
if she wants to
hmm well I guess not really
there's no consent no fairytale
so apparently so my favorite meme that
came from this was somebody took the
Sleeping Beauty like the Disney Sleeping
Beauty and it showed the Prince bending
and leaning in to kiss the princess and
then he gets very close and then he's
and then he says wait
she hasn't consented and then the next
picture is just a skeleton Sleeping
Beauty because she's dead right the
whole point of this of the fairy tale is
that she dies if you don't kiss her so
if the question is can you give someone
CPR to wake them up without their
consent the answer is yes you can in
life-saving situations if you like did
was there any guy who actually saw the
movie sleeping videos like oh man I'm
gonna party some rape chicks maybe was
there anyone who did that was there
anyone who watched - no white and like
aw that was did you see the hotness of
that non-consent with all the dwarves
sitting around hey really was that that
was their thing oh man look at all the
forest animals watching this is hot hey
it's just it's just absurd but this is
the point that we've reached the the you
anything will teach a boy apparently to
be a rapist and a girl to submit to rape
because that's our culture there's a
great irony in this okay Sleeping Beauty
came out and I believe 1954 1956
Cinderella came out around the same time
all of these came out in in the 50s and
60s all of the women who watched these
movies growing up ended up being part of
the 60s and 70s the most empowered group
of women in human history but what
happened didn't they
watch Sleeping Beauty and Cinderella yes
they did and you know what it didn't
teach them that they ought to let
themselves be raped my goodness you dolt
okay so other things that I hate Bernie
Sanders is is obviously attempting to
set up himself for a 2020 run which is
just great when will the boomers leave
us alone when when just go away guys
just retire hey Bernie Sanders the
octogenarian crazy loon bag from Vermont
he spent most of his life being
completely useless / counterproductive
and now has emerged to be useless and
counterproductive on a national scale
here Epson the president trim he says
President Trump is setting a terrible
example for our children right yeah I
got it dude I know I know but you're a
socialist and a crazy person I don't
understand how that's a solution to
president from setting a bad example for
our children children all the wrong
turns unlike Bill Clinton who received
oral sex in the Oval Office
unlike Ted Kennedy who drove a woman
into a river and let her die there
Donald Trump is uniquely bad uniquely
uniquely bad yeah I'm sorry I'm not
gonna hear it from people who are
completely silent about this sort of bad
activity from people on their own side
now I've been very consistent calling up
president Trump's bad behavior and I was
consistent in calling out Ted Kennedy's
behavior and Bill Clinton's behavior dad
behaviors bad behavior but the partisan
weaponization of bad behavior that I
find almost completely useless if you're
not gonna call it out on one side you
can't call it out on the other honestly
you have to be consistent in the in the
attempt to uphold virtue and I don't
strum the right to people who are
willing to let Donald Trump off the hook
for his personal behavior but rip on Ted
Kennedy and Bill Clinton don't work that
way either okay time for a quick
Federalist Papers so every week we go
through a federalist paper we are all
the way up to Federalist 48 making
steady progress this one written by
James Madison in this one Madison
continues to discuss separation of power
in Federalist 47 he began that
discussion he asks how the branches can
protect themselves against usurpations
by the other branches of government how
can the executive protect itself against
the legislature how can the judiciary
protect itself against both he points
out that there is that he thinks that
the real danger is legislative
usurpation this just demonstrates that
the modern form of government that we
have in the United States is very very
far from what we originally had we did
not have a regulatory state when the
United States was first created Madison
was not greatly fearful of the executive
branch usurping power or the judicial
branch usurping power because he
believed the legislature could simply
defund the executive branch or restrict
the jurisdiction of the judicial branch
both of which it has the power to do but
now in today's government it seems that
in many cases the legislative branch has
become almost a vestigial organ of
government except when it comes to
massive spending programs like Obamacare
but here is Madison's original case he
says the legislative Department derives
a superiority in our government from
other circumstances its constitutional
powers being at once more extensive and
less susceptible of precise limits it
can with greater facility mask under
complicated and indirect measures the
encroachments which it makes on the
coordinate departments so in other words
because the legislature has more power
and is given more power under the
Constitution that gives it more ability
to use sir power from the other branches
he argues that use for patients by the
executive and judiciary are unlikely why
because he says as the legislative
department alone has access to the
pockets of the people and has in some
constitutions full discretion and in all
a prevailing influence over the
pecuniary rewards of those who fill the
other departments that dependence is
thus created in the latter which gives
still greater facility to encroachments
of the former in other words the
legislature has the power to take away
money from the other branches restrict
jurisdiction we shouldn't have to worry
about usurpations now there's one
problem with the founding vision for how
the government was supposed to balance
itself the main problem is the
perception by the founders that the big
problem is going to be ambition right
what they said is ambition was going to
counteract ambition this is also said in
the Federalist Papers that the
legislators were going to be ambitious
they weren't going to stand for the
executive encroaching on their power the
executive is going to be ambitious the
executive wasn't going to a stand stand
for encroachments on on his or her power
same thing in the judiciary the problem
is the legislature because of these the
regulatory state
actually is not ambitious enough the
legislature now has an incentive to kick
every tough question over to either
judiciary or executive if it's a tough
constitutional question they don't feel
the necessity to argue whether its
constitutional or not they just say well
pass what we want what did you to Sherry
decide what it wants to do and they want
to pass laws that are highly non that
are highly nonspecific the more non
specific the better because if you pass
a law that says I want the executive
branch to do good stuff and then the
executive branch gets to fill in all the
blanks and the executive branch fills in
bad stuff you say hey that's not what I
passed I said I wanted them to do good
stuff you see this with environmental
legislation environmental legislation is
very often not detailed enough it gets
kicked over to the EPA the EPA does tens
of thousands of pages of regulations and
then Congress runs against the
regulations it gave the EPA the
authority to pass and the regulatory
state completely undercuts the bargain
between the branches the same thing is
true of the judiciary in other words
what we need is is a legislature that
attempts to grab back its power whether
we're talking in the context of War
Powers or in the context of
environmental regulation across the
board the legislature was designed to be
the first among equals not the President
and not the judiciary okay we'll be back
here tomorrow with more updates on the
migrant Caravan and all the rest I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jesuit Vera the Ben Shapiro
show is a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright Ford publishing